something went horribly wrong I'm a worm
murderer this month I tried to live zero
waste I had no idea what I was doing but
I learned along the way from just trying
not to make any trash day today and from
speaking to experts along the way the
average American makes about 4.3 pounds
of trash in one day and I'm going to be
trying to make no trash whenever I hear
about where the environments going I get
really scared and it makes me feel very
powerless how much waste is the average
person in LA make them up about 150
pounds per month Wow
I think this is gonna be really hard for
me and I'm like not necessarily really
looking forward to it I'm struggling
with how I'm supposed to eat because
most food comes in packages maybe I
should try to go into the woods and
forage for some nuts and berries I'm
having a hard time figuring out where
the line ends and begins I'm eating
these tacos and they're out of plates
maybe I'm not even supposed to be Davis
I wash my hands and I unconsciously
waved my hand now I have this I'm cranky
because I've been going hungry a lot so
I need to find a better solution than
just eating bananas how important is it
that we've reduced our waste and like
what's it really at stake for us if we
don't we're stewards on this land and so
every time we negatively impacted the
system we're actually jeopardizing our
ability to breathe drink water consume
food so I went to the store and I
brought my jars and I was able to fill
up with some quinoa from the bulk bins
and some other items the nice side
effect of this is that I am forced to
eat very healthy because I'm not able to
eat anything that comes in packaging
which is most processed foods I am
realizing that being able to do this
challenge is a privilege in itself
because a lot of like packaged
processed foods are the cheapest foods
and like fresh produce can be really
expensive but collectively I'm spending
less money these are the food scraps
from a stir-fry I made and I'm not going
to eat them but I can throw them away
I'm keeping my compost in my freezer
until I can figure out what am i doing
them I used to think that I needed
different soaps for different things but
now I'm realizing that soap is just so
this is a meal I made it was harder to
get all the ingredients are a waste but
feeling pretty good I'm here at Griffith
Park composting facility on a Saturday
morning and I'm gonna take a class to
learn how to compost I learned in the
workshop that a vermicompost would be
the best for an apartment that didn't
have access to soil so I set about
making one starting my in hell worm bin
and I have egg shells and egg curtains
for roughage then I have my red wigglers
I'm very excited so gross they're
burrowing down and they're gonna eat the
food scraps this is getting easier every
day and it's feeling really nice
actually
because I always would feel kind of bad
about all the trash that I was using and
it's awesome to like put that feeling
into action and actually do something
about it another zero waste no where
does the trash in LA go the trash goes
to a transfer station where it is sorted
and then it is trucked out to a local
landfill
so how many pounds of waste is sunshine
canyon taken per day about 8500 tons of
refuse in per day Wow majority of that
comes from the city of Los Angeles and
there's quite a few other facilities
around the area that handle the
remaining 70% if you think of the old
garbage dump right and they will refer
to it's nothing like that anymore so
these are highly engineered why does the
landfill have to close and what happens
to a landfill once it closes and the
landfill will reach a certain elevation
where then it can be closed and put back
as best as it can right to the way it
was before
unfortunately the trash is in there I'm
done and I feel very happy sad I made
this in a month tags from reusable bags
some advil hugs from the mason jars
delicious drumstick a tea bag this was
like what the socks came in plus I
couldn't reuse this part what can an
average person do to reduce their trash
reduce reuse recycle we all like to buy
things packaged real nice no and no one
touch them in reality that is creating a
lot of extra packaging we need people
start thinking about is the disposable
product that they're using really adding
that value to their life I think one
person can make a difference one person
can really evaluate everything that
they're consuming and make some changes
you don't have to give up everything but
let's start with one thing and what I've
noticed is it spreads throughout your
choices
[Music]